still upset over the prospect of never
getting to see zack snyder's version of
Justice League well grab your tissue is
because a newly released image from
Snyder's version of the superhero film
has teased a heartbreaking death that'll
be sure to get you welling up taking to
the social media platform Varro
Schneider shared a still from a scene of
his cut of Justice League which reveals
a crucial plot point in cyborgs
storyline the black and white shot shows
cyborg with his hand pressed against a
pane of glass looking on as his father
STAR Labs head doctor Silas stone is
apparently burnt alive in what appears
to be a containment chamber
it seems the fire may have been a result
of an explosion that involved a mother
box a powerful piece of technology that
appeared in both Snyder's Justice League
and the theatrical version directed by
Joss Whedon Snyder had planned to
explore an alternate history of the
mother boxes and his even shared
storyboard art that suggested his
Justice League would have seen cyborg
discussing the box's inception and their
connection to the Nazis during World War
two Snyder captioned the still from
Silas's death scene you would also cry
teasing the effect his take on Justice
League would have on audiences and
watching a beloved hero witness the
death of his father from just a few feet
away would no doubt be devastating so
Snyder isn't wrong there it's obvious
that Snyder's vision for Justice League
was going to be far darker than Whedon's
and including a death as emotional as
the one intended for Silas would have
brought the film to a somber place
indeed but evidently that isn't what
studio Warner Brothers wanted out of
Justice League particularly because its
predecessor Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice was slammed as a train wreck
largely thanks to its gritty tone rumors
about Silas dying and Justice League
swirled around the production for months
before its November 2017 debut and have
continued to the present day with many
speculating that his death would
establish the foundation for an eventual
cyborg solo film a pair of August 2018
tweets from the New York Times Kyle
Buchanan who cited a report by slash
film claimed that Silas did indeed die
in the original version of Justice
League buchanan wrote originally joe
Morton's character was killed halfway
through and cyborg finds a video from
him at the end that lets Morton's lines
play over the final montage Whedon gave
those lines to Amy Adams
but Whedon's reshoots also nixed the
Morton death scene so a wash
in that / film report Silas actor Joe
Morton confirmed that he filmed a ton of
scenes for Snyder's Justice League that
were scrapped when Whedon take over
Morton maintained his hope that the
sequences removed from Justice League
would be reworked for the cyborg
standalone and also told IGN that part
of the Justice League reshoots involved
adjusting cyborgs tone to quote lighten
up the film he explained there was more
we shot they completely changed the
story unfortunately I can't tell you
what the original story is because that
might end up being in part of the cyborg
movie yes there was a big change once
they decided that they were going to do
the cyborg film but whether the cyborg
movie ever ends up happening and whether
the film will actually include the Silas
death scene Snyder T's is a mystery
right now according to cyborg star ray
Fisher the standalone superhero flick
quote would be a very very costly movie
to make because it's so CGI heavy which
could explain why there hasn't been much
movement on it unfortunately rumors
recently began to surface suggesting
that the cyborg film is actually dead in
the water
we got this covered sighted unidentified
sources claiming Warner Brothers just
doesn't care about making any more
projects with Fisher ouch
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you